muchos franceses se han mostrado
indignados por los comentarios de macrón
sobre los no vacunados cómo reacciona
usted a las intenciones del presidente
de querer fastidiar a quienes se rehúsan
a la inoculación
en este momento se inició su campaña
entre cuatro meses tenemos elecciones
presidenciales ella toma la
responsabilidad
en este momento de decisión con palabra
hombre de elección
efe thaksin y él quiere a la gente que
no quiere seguir y dar protección a las
demás y ya son vacunados
y se le mencionaba se acercan los
comicios este debate sanitario parece
estar tomando inevitablemente dientes
políticos de cara a estas elecciones qué
opina de los bloqueos que ha enfrentado
el proyecto del pase vacunal en el
parlamento
pero en este momento tenemos la acción
más del tema contiene una oposición ya
se inició el día de hoy hoy tenemos una
crisis parlamentaria que se constituyó
para estar en contra de las
argumentaciones desde la estrategia que
tiene pues el tema con marc con que toda
la gente todos los concedentes de ser
vacunados
señor de orión y la implementación del
llamado pase sanitario ya había generado
un rechazo fuerte que se reflejó en las
calles de francia que se puede esperar
ahora si sale adelante el proyecto del
pase va con él mira yo hasta hace poco
asegura que 15 ya sí estuve en francia
yo tenía con mi pase sanitario tengo
derecho al restaurante teatro cine vivió
una vida correcta como siempre hemos
tenido hace hace dos años hoy yo puedo
decir que si se necesita con un semana
un gesto antes de saber que ha dado
asistencia social tenemos gente que no
tiene contagios